ici on va apprendre ensemble comment
faire un shampoing solide et zéro déchet
[Musique]
il suffit de frotter le shampooing en
fait entre ses mains comme du savon et
vous allez voir ça va mon c est vous
appliquez ça sur vos cheveux vous laver
les cheveux normalement moi j'utilise ce
shampooing depuis six mois maintenant et
je trouve qu'il est vachement plus
efficace que du shampoing de supermarché
[Musique]
quand vous faites votre propre show
point vous évitez évidemment du
gaspillage packaging parce que les
bouteilles de shampoing sont aujourd'hui
mal recyclés et finalement ça va être
plus économique
étant donné qu'une fois que vous avez
acheté tous les ingrédients vous allez
pouvoir faire votre propre shampoing
pendant des mois et des mois on va
utiliser de des huiles végétales vous
pouvez utiliser par exemple de l'huile
de coco qui est un grand classique et
qui va venir nous vers bosch vous pouvez
aussi utiliser de l'huile de jojoba qui
un régulateur de sébum extrêmement
puissant ensuite on va utiliser des
huiles essentielles les huiles
essentielles on les utilise pour leur
action qui est puissante et pour l'odeur
par exemple du titre i pour les cheveux
gras et avec des pellicules
on peut utiliser de l'ylang ylang plutôt
pour les cheveux secs
on va également utiliser des
tensioactifs sci qui vont permettre de
laver et de faire mousser et enfin on va
utiliser soit des poudres à hervé dic
soit dur à soul qui est un art gilles
soit des extraits de plantes telles que
l'ortie là encore en fonction de l'effet
recherché
[Musique]
les tensioactifs sci évidemment éviter
en contact avec les yeux pendant la
préparation
les huiles essentielles c'est très
puissant il faut les utiliser avec
modération est bien respectée la recette
et c'est déconseillé pour les femmes
enceintes les femmes qui allaitent les
enfants enfin on va utiliser des poudres
ailleurs védique ou de l'argile ou des
extraits de plantes qui sont très
volatils donc afin de ne pas avoir ces
voies respiratoires irrité il faut vous
méfier dans une pièce aérée et
idéalement mettez simplement en masque
pour vous protéger
c'est très amusant de faire son propre
champ points c'est bien plus efficace et
ça ne crée pas de packaging c'est
meilleur pour l'environnement et pour ma
santé
et c'est d'en produire zéro déchet
[Musique]